this is a pleasant surprise in real life
MBA 200 some pages and I was blown away
by the directness let me go to the quote
Jack which I thought you were especially
insulting on right now taking the grind
out of the game a leaders job is to
sweep away the action blockers the
change resistors the process obsesses
what are you been sitting in other
meetings these people are nothing more
than self-appointed self-righteous
scolds they drain energy I mean you were
directed this book why so direct look we
got to get this game back in its a fun
part of it that way
business is a game John and without
question the team that wins feels the
best players and this is all about
taking the the grinding boring since
2008 not enough people are engaged their
soul of fear right the the Gallup poll
shows 35% of the people are engaged 65
against it imagine that imagine going to
a game and 65% of your players stay on
the sidelines right let's go let's go to
chemi at Pittsfield Massachusetts to the
leading the fine life at Bain & Company
what did you bring those books OU's
everybody thinks is Jack Jack Jack yeah
but you did Bain four years I was I'm a
writer and an editor but a writer and
editor my whole life long so I was the
conceptual editor and the writer and I
would have to say contributed a few what
do we get wrong and are within our MBA I
just today well we have a chapter in
this book called getting whack and
getting better I mean I got an MBA I got
a Harvard Business School I didn't have
a course on getting whacked but in fact
that's what really happens in life I
mean that's what really happens in
companies that you've got a competitor
comes in like suddenly does some buys
your second biggest competitor and
suddenly you're the small guy or you get
fired and or you get whacked and so we
have a whole chapter on what to do when
you get waxed so that you can get out of
it what do we do but there's a list of
things you can do the book I mean I
think the first thing you do is you own
it you say I got whacked okay first
there's always a lot of denial and
coverup and you say I got whacked
here's what I did to contribute to the
whack and then there's several other
steps about changing the way you do
strategy and changing the way you
approach the market yeah but there's a
little bit of getting whacked in this
book and there's a little bit of being
the whack
her I mean that this is when you when
you when you talk about that quote that
Tom talked about the you know the action
blockers your advice in the book is very
clear get rid of them
fire them that's also a painful how do
you fire someone with dignity without
never anybody who is fired and is
surprised it's the boss's fault no
employees should ever be surprised and
that's one of the lessons of this book
we've talked to a million people if
we've gone around the world literally in
the last ten years and we ask people do
you know where you stand in your company
we don't get 10% of the crowd raising
they end people are working in a job
where their bosses are not telling him
what they need to hear to improve you
toe Olivia with that accent that he was
captain of Salem Mass in MVA now word
that I have a lot of friends at business
school they appear to be taking out huge
loans and spending about thirty thousand
dollars taking for there is a time and
place for an MBA if you've got two years
and the money and the flexibility to
give up the three hundred thousand
dollars involved in getting an MBA you
could go to a leafy campus go to one of
the top tier schools okay but there's
now you can get an MBA education get it
in a book or you can get it online
there's lots of ways I mean there are
certain people there may you get the
Jack Roush master students going here
but it's an online course and people
nowadays it seems me go to grad school
particularly for the season go to the
MBA for the social component for the
network well there's no question you're
right that that's the missing link in an
online school and we're working wildly
we had a meeting here with our new york
area graduates the other night I'm on a
webcast twice a month us our Dean is out
in the in the country meet meeting with
our students but it's hot that's a trade
you give up the socialization for the
look and you pay thirty nine thousand
dollars
ba you stay in your job you grow our
graduates are getting 65 percent of my
getting promoted 18 percent raises while
they're there you know I can't quote
from the Gospel according to Jack and
Suzy and we're to come back and talk
about we have to hold hands
service here we go sing Kumbaya here's
Jack Welch quoting sometimes you want to
go where everybody knows your name
pulling out all the Massachusetts
references you can come up is nor I'm
gonna show up for the next block Jack
and Suzy with us here as well